[Music]
welcome to the round table of dim
lighting I'm Micah I'm Colin and today
we're gonna see if we can remain
positive about some traditionally
frustrating or negative things yeah you
know there's there's a lot of negativity
in the world and most of it comes
directly from Mike and I yeah so we
thought it'd be a fun exercise if we
could just talk for a whole hour about
things that we know bothers the other
person but just doing our best to you
know possibly stay positive about it
yeah and thanks rhettandlink for letting
us do this is gonna be fun yeah it's
gonna be fun you probably have seen us
cooking some foods some delicious treats
and with power tools yep how are you
looking school yeah I almost got the
cooking with power tools is what we kind
of just call it that's the easier title
but yeah any easier well it's harder
actually there's more syllables I feel
like okay that's training with power
tools power cooking same yeah
well power tool cooking school
everything's a second there you know
that's the Google Bowl yes yeah but so
we came on and we decided that we wanted
to talk well this is already getting
difficult people may not know this about
us cuz we're we're we have such great
on-screen personas oh yeah we hide it
really well that weird both of us are
like fairly negative people I would say
were the most negative people that we
know at the office yeah or or in our
entire lives
maybe yeah you think so I I think we
might be I mean do you consider yourself
to be an overly negative person
absolutely yes I've worked on it for the
last ten years I've made a little bit of
progress but not that much yeah yeah no
I'm super negative a lot of times people
are all like I'll be an accidental
debbie downer bye-bye someone will be
like I had a I had a ham sandwich and
I'm like hams gross and that's that's
how I reacted it and then I go I'm sorry
that was really rude yeah because just
let someone enjoy their ham sandwich
yeah there's nothing to do with you and
your yeah so I don't know why I'm such a
some mystic person I mean it's so easy
to just default to it right it is yeah
it's just the easiest thing in the world
to look at everything glass half empty
and be annoyed all the time and just
like yeah
pointing out everybody's flaws and stuff
yeah you know I think it is what's that
for me at least it's like you I assume
that everyone's gonna be on board and be
like never gonna have a moment and we're
gonna get to like vent about it yeah
like it's the world right like you're
gonna be the one that rallies everyone -
yeah but really they're like you think I
like Thanks yeah so when I was in high
school yeah I saw this book cover yeah
and the name of the book was power of
positive thinking and I didn't read the
book I figured I would add it like okay
yeah think positively yeah yeah but
that's essentially what we decided we
wanted to do here we want to talk about
things
purposely that we know gets under our
skin and you know just really gets us
thinking negatively and then just you
have to talk about it positive we have
to we have to see the sunny side of the
road for one hour and I can emergency
you sweaty yeah I'm terrified of this
whole experience
I am I I do think we don't have any like
formal punishments mm-hmm which would I
mean we can berate each other I feel
yeah I think we just have to keep each
other on task you don't start going
negative I'm gonna have to be like and
well you know what Micah actually yeah
let's let's incorporate a little
positivity into it why not
why do punishments at all how about you
and odd reinforcement you and I
reinforce each other's positive behavior
for the last 40 minutes that's an
excellent idea call and let's just uh
let's just be happy and enjoy enjoy the
situation together that sounds amazing
and I love your shirt by the way thanks
I got it wardrobe because I realized we
were wearing the exact same shirt when
we came and sat down in here good
mythical morning
if you haven't heard of it check it out
yeah it's pretty popular um so yeah so
we're gonna have to try and be positive
about things that I prepared two things
that I think you will have a it will
hate and will have a hard time staying
positive about yeah you've prepared some
things for me as well yeah yeah and you
know what Mike I just want to say I'm
grateful for the opportunity to to
discuss these things in a positive way
right now this you've made it a
competition now well heaven is gonna
this is gonna get extremely positive
Thank You Colin for allowing me to be
graced by your presence here today at
the round table of dim lighting you know
what mica I appreciate you saying that
yeah and you're just super good at
making people feel good
Colin you're really good at thinking
people okay that was such a nice thank
you
I made you've made me feel just so
welcomed and appreciated and you know
what I'm just I'm having the best day
I've ever had that's awesome so here so
we've agreed on a topic yes is a
parameter that we put our ourselves into
yes and we put ourselves with a lot of
parameters today but I think it's the
perfect topic to stay positive on
because everybody has a thousand gripes
on this topic there's there's so many
things to get frustrated it's almost
cliched it's exactly cliches don't come
from anywhere oh don't come from nowhere
you know so that's why positive take on
the cliches it's universal it's
universal and that is why we chose it
and that topic is transportation the
most fun topic in the world yes you just
love like going to a new place though I
do I mean transportation enables us to
explore yeah and I actually I do really
love traveling it's been a long time
since I've been out of the country mm-hm
because I kind of burnt out and burnt
out on it yeah for a while but it is a
great thing to do I really have it I
agree I spent I spent the better part of
three years working on the road and
seeing almost all of the country
and few spots in Mexico and Canada and
it was an amazing opportunity and I
wouldn't like take that time back for
anything in the world you know yeah it's
really uh yeah
traveling is really important for the
Soul it is it is absolutely important
for the Soul and it's important to get
to appointments in the South Bay or
something you know yeah
Culver City yeah absolutely it takes
about the same time to get there as it
does to go to New Orleans no I've never
been to Nora great that's what I thought
okay so do you want to who should start
you want to you want to try and you're
gonna try and make me mad yeah well I
think I want to give you the opportunity
to see an annoyance of a new light okay
so what I want to talk to you about
right now is something just knowing your
personality yeah I know
can't wait here's the thing this is
something you guys may not know about
mica if it isn't a parent but Michael
loves rules oh yeah order and things to
be in their place and done a certain way
here's the thing I do love rules and
order it's only because I do not
understand humans and I need them to to
abide by the same set of rules that I
abide by in order to function in society
so okay so that's why it's it's it's
rarely is it like this is the best way
to do it but like I I do I do need
people to like I need I need a system in
order to understand what anyone's doing
okay you just can't relate to people on
like a human level it's pretty much it
okay gotcha
well then I think this one is gonna be
good because it does involve humans and
in a very I don't want to say intimate
but it's like personal person no no
traveling in an intimate way mica I want
to know your opinion of people who stand
on escalators let's say like I love them
you do oh yeah
all right the guys stay positive
especially wet well let's say they have
like a big roller bag or something so
there is no there's no opportunity for
passing okay well a roller bag that
you've you've now given them an excuse
to be standing there
really yeah roller bag on an escalator
pick it up by the handle oh that's true
well anyway this is your time hands are
they you know maybe they're not maybe
they're elderly and okay or I have two
broken arms or something
sure well that's nice I mean so you're
allowing context into the situation or
that is that's understand always might
be context great that's my motto
gosh okay standing on escalators
positive be positive you know sometimes
you just need to take a load off
yeah and you know it can get really
exhausting as being on the train or
whatever standing there on the train
sitting on the train and you have to get
onto an escalator it's like you don't
want to move those legs around you want
to mean to just you need to take take a
break you know yes that's some me time
that's thinking time it's like shower
time yeah because I do my best thinking
in the shower okay so maybe everyone
else in the room does their best
thinking on the escalator well I mean I
like to do my thinking on a nice long
walk which is sort of the opposite of
standing on an escalator because that is
a short mobile stand yes not only is it
great to stand on an escalator when
there are hundreds of people behind me
but you really want to what you really
want to do is buddy up you know you want
to grab a partner and stand side-by-side
oh that's nice really just because
because that way you can really connect
with your with your friend or with your
lover and or children whatever whatever
it is you know what gogo parent to
children three in a row just take up the
whole three wide three wide on Anne
Askew little ducklings yeah that's true
because that's bonding time you know
people are always in such a Go Go hurry
um up kind of state in the world so you
know it's important just to sort of take
like a moment that is true it can be
seen as like oh you're such a busy
metropolitan American rushing around
no time to just smell the roses again I
actually do understand that but I can't
have a but because I have to stay
positive I do understand that that point
of view is genuinely do you like sort of
having a moment where you have to like
take a breath and just accept know
what's right now it's forced on me I
will be nothing but stress okay it will
not be a relaxing moment if I'm if I'm
stuck in a in a situation I hate feeling
stuck in any in any in any capacity well
can you rephrase that without the light
inhaling unstuck there you go no but I I
gosh positive about escalators I've said
all I can say about it it's it really
yeah what if I were to give you okay so
this is you really tricked me in this
first one I this is hard if I were to
give you 30 seconds right now to be
negative about it and you think you
could fill that 30 seconds all right
well I'm not gonna do that because that
is not the premise of the show that's
that's fair enough physically yeah oh
you know what maybe at the end we could
blow off a little steam
there should be a section at the end
like you know what and I seem yeah
that's a good call because it's a good
call that I came up with uh-huh yeah but
I repeated it back to you so that's true
it's affirmation it is a thank you for
that that was a great a great idea yeah
but I mean that's important you know
there should be stress or reliefs and
and stuff like that that's true you have
to you have to get it out no one can be
positive all the time
right and we can be positive none of it
seems odd to me that it hasn't this
hasn't migrated to America because I've
seen it other places where it's right
it's a stand on the right walk on the
left kind of situation and everyone can
do whatever they want because ultimately
I truly don't care what other people do
yeah it's just when it affects what I'm
trying to do where I start to get
negative about it but I'm not gonna do
that now yeah they could lay down on the
escalator and I and I would I would love
it if there's room if there's room to
pass on the left here say no oh I'm
trying to be positive well don't you
could be positive but don't lie I want
to know your true feelings okay well my
true feelings are stand to the right
well there you go
okay how about this maybe next time you
see it here's a positive
way to look at it you can take that as
an opportunity to educate your fellow
travelers as to escalate eradicated
don't think I haven't thought about
doing that I would love to go around the
world and just do that as my job but I
think everyone would hate me and I would
have no friends well yes but that's like
a sacrifice an honorable sacrifice to
make if one day we could live in a world
where escalators are treated properly
that's true yeah well oh here's another
positive not genuine positive about
escalator standards is that if there is
a staircase yes
I always hundred percent take it now
sure but when there's not a staircase it
can be it can be frustrating but well
that's great though that's having you
get a little more cardio this is the
same with traffic I would rather take a
long route through neighborhoods that
will take me five minutes longer but
I've never stopped at that stop then
take the freeway
five minutes quicker but I'm stuck in
traffic the entire time yes
same for escalators yeah I hear ya I
mean it's a thing like sometimes when I
don't know how to get out of a
neighborhood necessarily like which
direction I have to go but I'm in an
area that I'm vaguely familiar with I
know if I get to this neighborhood I'll
be able to navigate myself home
so I'll do like Google for the first
part of it and I'll see that Google Maps
wants me to get onto the highway and
you're like no yes exactly so then but
that's great because I can spend some
time exploring a new getting lost and
you know and so you know yeah a
wonderful place to get lost
yeah I think that I think it says that
I'm there signs get lost and so you know
we're assuming you you weren't trying
together don't listen to them people of
Encino all right I have a I have one for
you okay let's see if you can stay
positive about this I think I have a
feeling that you're gonna hate that this
gun okay again I think that I think that
we probably have pretty similar thoughts
about all of these yeah so
it's easy to come up with one three
because I'm just one line what do I hate
that all right we live in a packed
metropolis it is and what a cultural hub
it is it is a cultural an opportunity
every day sorry go on
filled with people mm-hmm and all of us
people have their own car yes and
therefore there are twenty billion cars
freaking city and it can be it can be a
lot so and all those cars need to go
somewhere they need to be stored some
cots of motion
oh no they need to store dough stored
you're not because the other weird thing
about LA is that very little very few
driveways and garages especially for
people of our elk who can't afford their
own houses
so already getting like really upset
mica I'd say about fifty to ninety
percent of every Los Angelenos day is
spent looking for parking Street parking
but there are some people who apparently
haven't haven't taken the time to notice
their surroundings while parking mmm-hmm
there are there's a rampant issue of
parallel Parkers leaving too much space
between cars so that they take up maybe
a two-person a two-car spot with one car
they're positioned weirdly or they
position themselves a little too far
from the the driveway so that there's
like a half cars length in front of them
and behind them where a car could have
fit if they had just repositioned so
what do you think of that I think
there's literally no way I'm gonna be
positive about this you had you that
cuts me to the core of my being that is
the thing I have I have fantasies what
do you know what I like fantasies and I
like superheroes but I have fantasies
almost every almost every night because
it takes me about 20 minutes to park
when I get home from work because of
that issue specifically oh you do live
in a particularly bad area for that yes
and two blocks over there was a street
that was formerly not permit parking
only
about three months ago it became
permanent parking and now the whole
ecosystem is thrown into shambles oh wow
because everyone who used to park on
that street is now parking on my street
and well if I may call him yes here's a
positive spin on this okay
buy a permit um yeah I know you got to
get downtown and yeah I've got to find
parking there and it's all thing no no
IIIi should do that and you have then I
have all of that block yeah yeah no
that's that's a good that's a good
problem solve right then yeah and I I
think one they're not even expensive
they're very cheap it's just going to
City Hall that's that's taxing on your
soul that's a year's worth of salary I
would give up one year's worth of salary
to not go to City Hall ever again you
can't do it by mail no you can't do that
by mail but I just got my driver's
license renewed by mail yeah so that was
kind of cool
I opened the thing and it said this is
actually really positive I'll get to
your topic and I said that's fine I
opened the letter from the DMV which
normally you see a letter from the DMV
you're like oh great here we go but I
open it and in big bold letters at the
top it said congratulations you're
eligible for renewing your license by
mail yeah and I like that an eligibility
issue I guess I don't know it's you
ineligible I did not look that gift
horse in the mouth you don't have a
mailbox yeah what could it possibly be
you have to be like an upstanding
citizen I think it's probably if you
have like points against your license or
something like that or you may need to
take a new test or something like that's
some really like paternalistic behavior
there from the government it's like oh
you you're a bad boy so you can't do
this by mail there's no actual
functional reason why you wouldn't be
able to well if you need to retake the
exam okay yeah if you have like points
on your license and you need to retake
the exam you said then you're good I
just ignore that okay because I like
hearing myself talk and I got to say the
thing I said twice so welcome Thank You
Micah that's really kind of you but yeah
so all that aside a permit would be a
wonderful thing to have in my
neighborhood yeah but I Drive by and I
look at each and
every one of those cars four blocks
around and I see I it's a compulsion I
go three feet in front mm-hmm I'm like
foot and a half behind you just really
[ __ ] yourself yeah exactly like like
squeezing white-knuckle like there's
nail imprints in my steering but I had
this like fantasy that if I were Magneto
from the x-men
I would not be evil I would just adjust
people's cars for them yeah all day long
I would fly around the city moving cars
a foot and a half day all day is the
most altruistic superhero imaginable
okay that's better than fighting baddies
or aliens or whatever it's those fights
cause entire cities to be destroyed yeah
you're sure you're good even good guy
but you still destroyed all of New York
this all you don't the only evil you're
fighting as misuse of space exactly I'm
gonna brilliant you should write that
comic I also when I was a kid I also
wanted to be able to make quarters
appear by opening and closing my fist
that would devalue the cordon well no
but here's the thing it's kind of a scam
but you know oh we don't need to talk
about capitalism
I had the fantasy of walking around and
just feeding parking meters oh no no
that's nice that would still
theoretically devalue the quarter right
but the inside the meter and take them a
while to figure it out unless you're
unless your power is that you can take a
quarter out of a bank fault in Oakland
yeah that would be into that or just
like right out of the mint sure
brand-new would be one that they were
already making because you have the
power to just manifest money then it
devalues money right I mean I think
money's it's an extreme sense it doesn't
make any sound it's stupid it's a stupid
idea but we love money would you love it
we love it I don't think we're doing a
great job of being okay so great
actually been positive about a bad
parallel parking okay I'm going to try
but first let's take a break and talk
about some really cool t-shirts sure
yeah
all right you ready for that I would
love to okay because this is actually
something that I think is pretty cool
and is easier to be positive about
first alright so this one I like a lot I
like the color
I think this would actually look really
good on you Micah it would this is
exactly this is my color palette right
here it's a it's like a seafoam green I
don't know if there's an official
official color code for it that we
should be we should be talking about but
I do love that color I do too and I like
it I personally it's not really in my
wheelhouse but neither is this
monstrosity that I'm wearing and it
looks great on you I think especially in
this lighting the lighting really really
it just I don't know makes everything
look good yeah but this is the this is
the good mythical summer tank it's look
at this typeface yeah I really like it I
like the yellow on the green I think
this is a pretty darn cool tank turned
out and I think it may also come in a
racerback for ladies is that a thing yes
oh and I think it comes in a couple
different colors too oh no way yeah you
can get that at no it does not we're
couple different color slight variance
on this shade you can't the untrained
eye wouldn't be able to tell but yes so
this comes in men's and women's sizes
you can find it with all the summer
merch which is like a t-shirt a towel
sunglasses yeah at
rhettandlink.com/store nice that's
rhettandlink.com/store
I'm a mumbler we've also got this guy
right here this is I want my GMM as in I
want my MTV okay and if you're old
enough to remember that was MTV slogan
in like the late 80s I think right and
if you're not old enough to remember
just fake it till you make it kids yeah
you know now you know and you can
pretend like you always knew exactly and
that's very cool I had a firehouse
t-shirt when I was a kid if you're not
familiar with the 80s hair band
firehouse neither was I when I bought
the t-shirt but now I love to hate them
oh so I don't ever heard of them there
they're terrible
I'm not terrible no this is great this
is a very cool retro throwback I want my
GMM yes a t-shirt that you can also find
everything calm slash store I got it
through at that time without mumbling
good job man thanks that's uh
incremental improvements yeah that
measurable - that's really that's nice
huh
it's a good thing I appreciate that yeah
of course dude Wow now back to being
Mojave okay yes so
I suppose the good thing about that is
it allows less considerate people easier
access to leaving their parking spots
mm-hmm and potentially driving away from
my neighborhood maybe never to return
yet they get to drive away a little
quicker yeah they get to drive away a
little quick a little quicker they can
head back to WeHo and I don't have to
have to think about them anyway you're
assuming that they all live in we yeah
there's also a dearth of parking there
too Oh what is it Earth I think I used
that that term right it's a lack okay
yeah it is right now Dirk this is
fascinating radio a scarcity or lack of
something you you called you your your
your not knowing that word made me
question if I knew the word sure I mean
I know I know few of the words in the
English language not all good many of
the word mm-hmm but okay so yeah that's
that's one way to look at it and I
suppose I get it here's the thing I am a
bumper bumper yeah and I can understand
your perspective of not wanting me to
just hit your car yes because I want to
park and be done that is what bumpers
are for but it's like really in the
title isn't it yeah there's a bumping I
think they're great for bumping they're
they're tailor-made I don't know why
steel bumpers went away from cars steel
bumpers were great were they sure like
on old trucks they not like fly out
through windshields and like oh that
might be old or something that sounds
like sudden yeah Ralph Nader probably
had a crusade against yeah Ralph Nader
what a what a fun pool because the seat
belt thing cuz the seat belt thing yeah
he he is he was responsible for see
boats being he invented the seat belt
and he is the co-creator of the Internet
yeah yeah Algor the original seat belt
was it was a man's belt mmm that was
clipped onto these these sharp steel
hooks that was
randomly put into cars for no
discernible reason and you just like
slipped your belts into it wrap it into
your pants hmm
and then if you got into an accident you
would still go through the windshield
but then you would swing back so at
least you stayed with your car that's
the important point when it get to the
scene of the crime the crime the crash
you're still in your car and that's
Ralph okay you just gave me the most
like horrible memory do you remember in
driver's ed when you had to watch a red
asphalt I don't think I ever watched
that you didn't watch that one may have
but yeah I know the general idea yeah so
I remember I was in driver's ed and our
wrestling coach who taught driver's ed
of course well wrestlers are classically
great driver yeah absolutely
everybody knows a thing the knowledge
base the knowledge base of one one area
transfers to run for one one for over to
the other absolutely
they make great health teachers as well
he was describing to the class this idea
is like no a lot of people don't want to
wear seatbelts because they think that
if they get into an accident they'll be
thrown from their car to safety
he thought that that's why he said it he
used to think that he still does think
it just they're forcing him to teach the
opposite he thinks that he thinks that
[Laughter]
it just blew my mind the thought process
of flying through a pane of glass and
landing like 50 feet away somehow is
safer than being when you when you eject
from the car you can land safely in a
patch of grace a nice soft billowy patch
of grass which is readily available I
mean I know you grew up in the same
place as me but that is like an eerily
good impression of my high school
wrestling high school coach sounds like
in Chicago I
there's got to be something that I
genuinely think is good about this I'd
like I'm determined now I have an idea
okay please it's not necessarily good
that comes from it but it is a positive
spin on it okay
I so I was in Minneapolis two
Thanksgivings ago my sister-in-law is
from there so my whole family went the
goes every year to her family's place
that's nice yeah
and I've I went for the first time
joining them two things it means ago and
one of the most remarkable things that I
noticed was it was a nice city big city
real city the cool really cool stuff
called neighborhoods etc this sounds a
little like a little mouse under English
it was like it was like going to an
actual city guys I'm practicing with
this because I what I'm about to say
that there was so much parking yeah was
just abundant and free and joyous it was
it was a happy moment I mean like it was
like a fun experience he go take your
car and you park wherever you want you
you literally just stop your car get out
it's fine doesn't matter yeah in
Minneapolis you don't need to worry
about oh how close I'm on the curb and I
am I gonna be screwing someone over by
not pulling up enough etc oh well a Mini
Cooper could fit here I mean probably a
Mini Coopers here last should I leave
more room or less room etc yeah and you
know do that math sometimes it's like I
can leave this much yeah this much
behind me although you know sorry not to
cut you up but do you get out of your
car and reap arc if you okay god I love
you mica yeah I can everyone just get
out of your car and reap arc if you
dinner I have human empathy it takes it
takes so care about my fellow man leave
your car understand them but I care
about that that's yeah leave it running
get out and check get out and check a
quick check two seconds you know what I
got eight inches I don't
I'll take those eight inches what'd you
say I said I've got 8 inches I'll take
them eight inches is what I'm saying
okay but they'll throw at the park key
sometimes a parking spot is just a
parking spot my recurring theme with
things that you say to me you said that
in our smoker video about a grill being
just a grill yeah yeah anyway what I was
getting at was that that parking like
that is a luxury yes it's it means it
means that you're carefree you
you you come from a place where this
daily stress is not a part of the life
there mm-hmm
so so if they're almost there almost
contributing they're almost acting as if
la is a paradise when it's not so it's
like bringing a little bit of paradise
back to LA okay so it's it's almost like
an escape and actually as much as this
does bother me I will admit that I have
done it and I've justified it in exactly
the way you described it's it's like I'm
exhausted or whatever my excuse is
there's no excuse for this kind of
behavior no and I don't wanna I don't
want to seem like it's something we
should be doing but I remember at one
point thinking like I earned it today
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna go all
mirrors iron turning my neck either make
someone else's suffering I are someone
else's suffering for my fleeting my
fleeting happiness and you know what I
do have I mean we live in a society so
yeah that is that the downfall of our of
our civilization hmm is that when you
have something someone else doesn't
Melissa excusing pad behavior because I
want to oh yeah yeah well it's what's
something I want though yeah look man
I'm telling you this is like this is
maybe twice in the seven years I've
lived and no I you know you I know you
you're a good person it's fine you
everyone makes mistakes
yeah exactly I've parked like like a
jerk everyone back I've come back to my
car and seen that I parked like a jerk
and not realizing and felt I felt were
horrible ORS that happens one time one
time I parked this is crazy
okay I I lived in my place for like a
year I was in a particularly bad space
mentally everything was going wrong
mm-hmm and for about six months right
after I moved into my place okay toward
the end of this period my car got towed
I wake up in the morning to a text from
my neighbor saying I think your cars
getting tired oh no no it didn't say
that it said I think your card just got
towed oh cool thanks for a timely timely
text it's good that she text me at all
because
yes otherwise it would have cost way
more cuz it's like by the hour yeah so I
went out indeed my car was not there I
called the number found the place it
turns out that I parked in front of my
neighbor's driveway oh I have no idea
how that happened how I achieved that
wonderful feat mm-hmm but and I even
asked I was like I can't imagine this is
true that this really has not me not me
so I asked the tow truck driver for
pictures like oh yeah I got pictures and
he showed me and sure enough I was right
Wow I felt so bad about Bor like like
2/3 in my car right in front of well I
have to imagine that there's like this
weird situation where there's like a
fake driveway hmm right on the corner
and then a real driveway and so
sometimes people like Park in weird ways
there or like cover half of the real
driveway because they live there
something like yeah yeah yeah so I have
to imagine I just filled in that space
and didn't realize that didn't pay
attention yeah but even if I did I don't
know how it happened but um but it cost
me like $250 to get my car out and play
the ticket and everything and I wrote I
wrote a note and put it on the mailbox
that I was like hey I'm the guy who
parked in front of your driveway
yesterday I'm really sorry I have no
idea how that happened and anyway sorry
I just like wrote a little note because
I felt really bad for that they had to
deal with that in the morning you're a
wonderful person right yeah that is I
the the the the biggest emotion I felt
was stupid yeah like with myself yeah I
mean I was a little embarrassed but that
wasn't even it because I think
embarrassment can lead to people acting
out you know okay
hide it they're like well I if I'm
pregnant then I probably am right but
that wasn't even part of it it was like
I was like just kind of it'll oh yeah
although I was like yeah I do
just feeling annoyed yeah with my own
baby I mean that's great you see I I
lived in a house that had a driveway
right off of a pretty busy street right
off of Sunset Junction which is like a
lot of shops a lot of bars and
restaurants very busy very popular and
they're kind of intense about the
parking over there ticketing and
citations and stuff so it is a difficult
neighborhood to parking and I'm glad
that I had a driveway when I lived there
that's nice it was very nice but pee
would park in front of our driveway
constantly day and night we were blocked
in all the time and it takes about four
to five hours to get a tow truck really
yes
takes about four to five hours they
aren't the thirsty to get you would
think so but it's like it's tow truck
companies and the city of Los Angeles
are kind of like cats if you pay them
any attention they are looking out the
window but as soon as you're trying to
like sleep or eat
yeah they are on top of your chest like
licking your and yes because when I got
into an accident there were like six tow
trucks Deb's showed up before the cops
did because they heard it on the on the
radio they listened in to the in to the
cops radios yeah yeah and none of them
were triple-a and the cop at it was like
mate he was like before I leave your
triple-a right I think I was like yeah
and he left not triple-a and so he ended
up leaving me and I had to call triple-a
Wow yeah he was trying to take me to his
buddy shop in like Beverly Hills which
is not where I got into the accident and
there's nowhere near it yeah yeah anyway
so that's surprising that they want to
take advantage and make what you would
think so but he's but here's my point so
we used to leave
we actually positive spin my roommates
and I would have a great time
drafting passive-aggressive notes for
these cars yeah things like hey like I
hope you I hope you have a good time at
you know bar Stella today and it would
be great if you got back here before the
tow truck arrives but it has been called
stuff like that we do stuff like that
then no I mean won't get to them until
they get to their car so it right well
my hope is that the tow truck comes it
gets impounded and then they go pick it
up and there's a note waiting for it the
ticket yes that that's my hope of hopes
huh but we if I ever received that note
that you wrote I would be like instantly
olea leaved of all my aggression get all
that like pain and I'm like what idiot
I'm sure they were men of course why
wouldn't you be so yeah hopefully that
leaved it yeah yeah no it's very
frustrating but yeah you know what I'm
proud of you mica hey thanks buddy
yeah absolutely see I exist in a society
I've been
I think about I think what the way my
actions affect other people a lot like
maybe too much yeah it could could be a
thing I'm not saying I'm like I can
absolutely be a jerk but yeah but I it's
just like I don't know it's a weird
thing that I was like always floating
around in my head yeah no I understand
what you're saying but no no I feel the
same way man you know what because when
you're when you're as good as we are and
we responded being positive that's right
which we've done a great job of doing
yeah and do you have more for me I do I
have some notes on the floor I can go
for you want another one yeah ready yeah
yeah well we'll keep these ones quick
okay yeah we'll do this one lightning
sound okay here we go
this is to stay on the tangent of cars
okay cuz it's just sort of classic mode
of transportation in LA it's one of the
only ones yeah yeah so how do you feel
about there's another sort of etiquette
question - four-way stops like stop
signs uh-huh
have I find often that when people
arrive at a four-way stop sign they will
just drive through it regardless of
whose turn it may be yeah I find that as
well I actually find that it's neat that
new that's a new phenomenon yeah yeah no
I like honestly within the last year
four-way stops have gotten to become
free-for-all there's anarchy I don't
know what it is I don't either
so this this is a good one it's a yeah
let me try to be positive about this so
this it happened this morning actually
there's there's one stop between my
house and work that this this is like
the biggest example of this phenomenon
where it's just like because there's a
school it's like parents on their way to
or from dropping the kids off at school
mmm-hmm so I was at the stop you know
it's four ways and these two cars got
here went as I was arriving so the how
do I even the particular the
perpendicular street went red as out
okay so then there's me and the car
across from me
and facing me that car you can make eye
contact are you like hey buddy we're in
this we're in this together and that car
is turning left so usually I don't I
actually don't remember what the rule is
for this but that I let that car go
first usually okay so that car turns
left and then I go and as I'm coming in
the middle of the intersection I know
and this is full full stops there's like
five cars at each stop sign yeah the car
right behind the car that just turned
left starts going I was like in what
world is this your turn in what world
buddy in in the positive world where you
know what the people have you know some
people are having a bad day they have to
rush somewhere they have they have it's
no fun to rush it's no fun to rush and
you know what you don't know I don't
know what that second left Turner was
doing mm-hmm maybe he or she was trying
it got it got a text message from their
loved one mmm that they're choking it's
like oh you just dropped off the kid
well guess what I'm at home choking
mm-hmm on like an entire hotdog can you
text 911 Oh probably not you can barely
call a man it takes about 15 to 20
minutes to get through what did you have
to call 9-1-1 okay i'm fine i call it
every everyday just still there just in
case yeah yeah no I've called 9-1-1 it
was a terrible experience it wasn't in
LA I was calling on behalf of my friend
I was in Chicago my friend was in San
Francisco she called me on her cell
phone on her way home from a bar as
women sometimes do too for a safety
issue okay
but it turns out after this happened I I
kind of was reading up on it and it's
not actually the best tactic a better
tactic to remain safe on the streets is
just to be alert and I have anything in
your years supposedly but so she calls
me were chatting in the middle of it she
yells an obscenity which I will not
repeat on this podcast sure the bad one
the real the you know the real heavy one
and
it's not that bad the f1o okay it's just
the worst one oh there's so much worse
than yeah I guess you're right you
terrified the classically bad one and
drops the phone or you know the phone
cuts out and I'm like oh my god yeah
yeah my friend just got murdered yeah
so I call my 1 1 and I get Chicago 9-1-1
yeah
and I'm like so my friends in San
Francisco and she just dropped the phone
and screamed and and they're like okay
hold on and I hear the woman could chunk
a binder onto the desk
flip through the pages it's about a four
minute processor San Francisco do you
know where no okay okay do you have a
pen and paper and I was like no hold on
I had to go find pen and paper she reads
me off a number for the San Francisco
Police Department
I call them they will not open a case
and let they can't make a case number
unless they have an address
you don't know why so I didn't have I
didn't even know where she lived I don't
know what bar she was at where she was
going yeah and I didn't know what part
of stammers cause she was in mm-hmm
so I couldn't open a case so every time
I had to like get new information like
call friends to find her address cetera
I had to go through this process all
over again start from but yeah I didn't
call Chicago 9-1-1 every time yeah I
just wanted to check in the day and just
let her know what it was happening she
seemed worried so yeah so this took a a
total of about 25 to 35 minutes uh-huh
mmm just to like get that like any of
this happening and then before they
could even send a cop out she called me
from her sister's phone I was like I got
mugged I'm fine my phone they took my
phone I'm at my sister's house now Wow
yeah so good thing that's all what
happened cuz yeah that had me a happy
ending yeah but that's my that's my name
alone experience but four-way stops yeah
I think I said all I can say about it
you know if you if you if your loved one
is choking at home you're who cares
about these other people you got to get
where you gotta go that's true
prioritize yeah the people in your life
are the truly the greatest treasure it
of course yes yeah if you have to piss
off a couple strangers in order to save
a loved one mm-hmm
well worth it absolutely and then just
go back to that four-way stop right hand
written note I'm so sorry but my
behavior yeah my daughter will be fine
yeah she's thank you for your
understanding not to eat whole hotdogs
without chewing ATM right that's more of
a lunch item than a breakfast item all
right I got one final one for you I'm
gonna take it away from cars okay let's
go friendly skies all right listen you
talked about how this was a little
cliche in general this topic mm-hmm but
this is the most cliche part of this
cliche topic is air travel right every
time every every stand-up comedians good
joke about what's the deal with
airplanes they're so crazy why the
peanuts
I got a tight twenty five on it man well
we got time with us listen it's not
tight it's a loosey goosey 20 it is just
just a wobbly and flimflamming and
hopping around i mean air travels in
nightmare I would much rather travel by
train if it were in an aisle option yeah
it takes so long to get through the
airport etc the thing about train travel
is I find that there's far too many
murder mysteries breaking out there are
yeah a lot of murders happen on trains
come on and there are all mysteries
they're not easily solved there's some
mysterious well that's good they're
going through the tunnels I mean that's
what I always strike dark in there yeah
yeah but anyway airplanes the thing that
I wanted to discuss is while you're in
the in the air mm-hmm I just got the
burbs there's gonna be inevitably
someone sitting next to you yeah god
forbid you have the middle seat and then
you got two people next to you yep but
there is only one armrest Colin and that
is a battle to be fought because who
gets it how do you split it up what is
the unspoken agreement here between you
and your neighbor elbow fighting on
airplanes the unspoken agreement is give
it to the middle seat
mmm yeah I like that give it to the
middle seat yeah I am I'm a firm
believer in that I don't if I have an
aisle or a window I don't put my arm on
the middle you got one already I've got
one and you know I've either got a view
or I've got easier access to the
bathroom like whatever you know there's
like compromises and stuff so I that the
person in the middle should have it
automatically this should be an
announcement on the plane before you my
god established law there should be a
law about this this man so much sense
the middle seat it's the worst seat they
should get to everyone's bummed
everyone's bummed to have the middle
seat you know because a lot of times I
travel a lot and I actually I don't like
necessarily the act of flying but I love
I love having access to airplanes you
give so much access to airplane I have a
lot of eggs I have more access to
airplanes than a lot of people you could
go get on airplane right now we are
letting the street do we were like seven
minutes from an airport yeah no that's
access right there that is access and
two airplanes yes so although the one
that we're close to doesn't fly anyway
it does it just costs a lot of money and
stops in Phoenix yeah yeah so basically
it's a it's a bus to fina it's a bus to
Phoenix to get on an airplane to go to
Chicago on the 10 no but I have had that
situation I mean I so I went uh I went
to Ireland about six seven months ago I
can't remember where I got that sure
that's where I got this lovely Irish
shirt traditional Irish garb for
listener he's wearing a green tie-dyed
t-shirt that has appeared on the
mannequin I believe in GMM episodes
that's right it has an hour body swap
episode yeah but so that's a that's a
long flight and with the time change
time change and layover
it took me exactly 24 hours to
- OH Dublin from LAX that's a trade off
so like I took off at 8:45 in the
morning and I landed at 8:45 in the
morning the following day ok but but as
an exit 24 hours no it wasn't it was
it's disorienting right it is for sure
so then I'm there for that I'm there for
a while I was there for like two weeks
and it was wonderful I had a great time
and yeah yeah I thought it was the
magical experience etc yeah yeah air
travel on the way back I you can imagine
I'm pretty exhausted right it's been a
long trip and I'm about to get on to
this very excruciating plane and I draw
the middle seat on the way back I had
the window on the way there so I'm like
that's fine it's a balance you know I
can I can be positive about it yeah the
universe is in balance I'm but I was
feeling a bit territorial mm-hmm cuz
it's you know my fight yeah
so I established early my dominance over
the armrest yeah like locked in like
little claws over the end of them you're
an alpha traveler it's right there on
your ticket yeah yeah I just wanted to
make sure because as much as that should
be a rule that you just out of the
kindness of your heart give it to the
person in the middle a lot of people
don't know and so sometimes you just you
just got to take what's yours mm-hmm and
so I did I went for it and uh dude next
to me I swear to God for like wait nine
and a half hours yes can I guess so he
did do you want to do you want to do an
act out yeah I know put his arm on top
of your arm as if here I would love that
that would be a hilarious no no he did
that so you you be me and I'll sue
instead what he did was just sort of jab
my elbow with his and then took a
centimeter of the armrest so for nine
and a half hours our forearms are just
touching just full lock the whole flight
man and I couldn't budge I couldn't give
him an inch because I he can't win he
can't win in this situation because this
is this isn't about my ego this
about like good versus evil you know I
couldn't allow him to have that like I
almost didn't go to the bathroom the
entire flight because I didn't want him
to have the opportunity yeah but I
reached this tipping point where I
almost like screamed because you know I
didn't really have a bed for two weeks
and like I was traveling I was you know
anyway there was no like creature
comforts for the last two weeks in my
life and I wanted so badly to not be
touched right by another human being
right for like eight minutes and I could
have like just let it all go but he
wasn't allowing that for me if I could I
just had if I could have just had my
safe little bubble though for a few
moments I could have gotten through it
but I that's the worst part about
traveling especially if ice I don't know
if you got like hotel rooms for yourself
if you're doing hostels and I was just
doing hostels that's it's exhausting
because you have no you have you at no
point for the four two and a half weeks
or however long in there you don't have
you have no bubble you have no personal
space at all and that is really taxing
but it is taxing but I mean that is that
was my entire tent intention of that
trip was to put myself into a different
sort of mind yeah he wanted to be I was
like feeling a little too good about
myself surrounded by people
no probably would uh when I was staying
in Dublin um I hate it this is
travel-related
sure yeah when I was staying in Dublin I
hated the hostel I was in so badly but
it was like the weekend of a big like
football match so like there weren't a
ton of options and so I went across the
street to Trinity University and for
like two days in a row
I just spent my afternoons taking naps
on campus of like it's a pretty good old
200 year old University it was just like
it was lovely that's a really good idea
yeah I watched like you know the kids
playing rugby practice and stuff like
that so there's always pick up a couple
tricks I guess this is my positive take
yeah I'm the elbow space and
no matter what is happening to your
elbow you can always escape into the
world of fonder memories and it's so
it's a practice in stress management
it's a practice and sort of just you
know like a zen-like quality where you
can when you when you when when the
world the exterior world is causing you
stress you can move inside yes focus all
of your energy on centering yourself
right or into a fiery ball rage I once
had a guy in a plane well I've had I've
had a lot of elbow things yeah yeah I
once had a guy on plane I was sitting in
the window seat I believe this energy
was open which is nice oh oh I thought
you were gonna say he sat in it anyway
no no well this is maybe crazier than
that but I actually have had a lot of
good luck on planes getting the center
seat open I've got next to me but he was
on the aisle and I'm just chillin in my
seat and and he starts to talk to me and
I'm kind of like I don't want to talk to
someone on a plane that's kind of my
general MO but he asks me if we can
switch because he likes to look out of
the window this is just a man just a 45
year old European man mm-hmm
well-dressed just a guy he's like hi can
we switch the can I have the seat you
paid for so I can look out the window
was just I mean I guess but here's the
thing is that I'm so uncomfortable with
this kind of interaction that I was like
okay and I let him have it for a couple
minutes and I went to the bathroom when
I came back I was like and we switch
back oh well okay yeah but my normal
inclination would not be to give me well
yeah I mean I get it I would never
impose myself on someone like that
because a crazy imposition yeah but I
would rather think about a grand scheme
of things it's not all that horrible of
a thing to have course not it was not
what and if you're a person unlike you
or I someone with a backbone maybe you
could have said no obviously you and I
sit next to that guy for the rest of the
Ranger of the flight right now that's
awful and he it was just weird phrasing
he was like I couldn't I don't want to
do in a European accent because it's
maybe offensive so I do it in my normal
voice because like um can we switch I
like to look that's great for you that
you like to look I also like to look I
went to subway got a roast beef sandwich
and then a guy with a tuna sandwich was
like hi can we switch I love roast beef
[Laughter]
this is my sandwich it's not I'm not I'm
not automatically entitled to all the
roast beef in the world just because I
bought the sandwich but this sandwich is
my sandwich right I don't think you're
crazy but that was not pot in there
[Music]
either man you know so I know we talked
about early about maybe doing like a
negative thing to blow off some steam
but I think we got that out of the way I
think we did I think most of you do you
want to just real quick before we go
just say something that like makes you
happy to sort of just like be like
genuinely positive yes I can't but I'm
gonna need a minute to think of
something okay I've got one locked and
loaded
spending time with my friend Micah oh
yeah well you really put me in a
position now well you better respond the
way I expected you would we do spend a
lot of time together because we work
everyday together and we're on an improv
team together
yes it's six days a week occasionally
seven yeah every once in a while seven I
okay uh you know I'll return the favor
but I am genuine I like being in scenes
with you oh we we perform and prep
together and I Colin's a real fun guy to
be in a scene with I'm gonna do but it's
always a good move oh he's your toes but
he you know he supports the scene he
makes it fun that is that is honestly
really nice and really great
thanks man that makes me feel really
good about myself dad I'm glad thanks
dude all right well guys this is uh Ben
Mike and eyes episode who these get
screw biscuits thanks for listening I
hope you were able to make it to the end
of this yeah I hope that we that we said
anything remotely possible yeah it's
hard to remember it's all a blur it's
like a white like a whiteout
yeah yeah but I think I think we tried
to find at least one positive spin on
every negative thing that we brought up
yeah um all right thanks everybody
thanks guys
[Music]